- The Rebel Alliance insignia
is atop her tiny head.
(light instrumental music)
- I don't think I was an animal person
until I had these rabbits.
So, before this year I
was kinda going through
this three to four year isolation binge,
and then I met someone and she happened to
have one rabbit and ever since then I just
blossomed in this relationship,
we now live together,
and now we have two rabbits.
- I'm here today to get
a tattoo of my daughter.
She's a black cat named Jyn.
I picked the name Jyn for a reason.
She's named after the character
in Rogue One, Jyn Erso.
When I adopted Jyn.
She was actually adopted
as a kitten by a family.
The family ended up abandoning
her and she was literally
found wandering the streets in the rain.
It's so cheesy, but I'm a cat lady
and she's really one of my best friends
and I want her immortalized on me forever.
- I am Adam Parrot.
I am a tattooer here in
Los Angeles, California
at Rabble Rouser Tattoo.
I've been tattooing a
little over 10 years.
I'm excited to give people
tattoos of their pets
so they can have them with them forever.
How's it going?
I'm Adam. I'm gonna be your tattooer.
What are you looking to do today?
- [Tyler] I'm getting my
rabbits tattooed today.
- [Adam] And what are their names?
- [Tyler] So, the big
one is named Jiji after
the black cat in Kiki's Delivery Service,
and the little one is Kiki.
- We are getting a tattoo of
my daughter who is a black cat.
It's gonna be going on
the back of my left calf.
- Okay.
- I'm looking to get something on my arm.
I'm thinking like somewhere in this area.
- Okay and then you mentioned
having it also framed?
- Yes, I'd love to have some
kind of frame around her.
I'm pretty much open to
anything as long as at the
end of it there's a cat on me.
- Okay, cool.
Thanks guys!
Alright, you ready to check it out?
- I'm so excited!
- [Adam] Alright.
Here's what we got.
- Oh my God, yes! I love it.
That's amazing.
I mean, that looks exactly
like what they love eating.
- Oh my gosh.
I love it.
I want to put this in a locket
like fuck getting it on my calf
we're just gonna do it on my face.
Put this on my body now!
- Awesome.
(alternative rock music)
Okay. We're done.
Check it out?
- Yes.
- Oh yeah.
That's super amazing.
They look so cute.
I can't wait to show my girlfriend.
- [Adam] And the bunnies.
- [Tyler] Yeah, and the buns.
They're gonna be the
most excited about this.
- Oh my goodness.
Are you kidding?
It looks so good.
It looks just like her.
Somehow you've captured her
eyes and her dumb expression
that she has on her face constantly.
The orange background is
like what sets it off.
- This really turned out amazing.
- Sweet! Awesome.
- Thanks, man.
- Thank you.
- So I just got home
from the tattoo shop and
I'm about to show
Michelle and the buns the
tattoo I got today.
- What.
They're so cute.
These are my buns!
- [Tyler] Hey buns.
You wanna see the tattoo I got?
Look at you guys.
- [Allie] So this is Jyn's
reaction as I'm trying to
show her that I've
committed to having her face
on my leg for life.
Just disinterest.
And this is Jyn's reaction to the prospect
of getting a treat.
(cat mews)
(light dance music)